going back earlier to something i said
about um their first script
a writer's first script being the the do
all and end all and
you said to have several like two or
three yeah can you talk about
those two or three scripts that that
writer should have in their arsenal
yeah um an important factor with that uh
most writers want to showcase how
talented they are and so they'll write
two or three scripts that are completely
different
they want to showcase that they can do
drama that they can do
family that they can do something else
not only should a writer focus on the
gold mine genres
it's really important that they focus
that those two or three scripts are the
same goldmine genre
and the the thing a writer will say
instantly is when i get when i get like
known just for writing that one thing
and the answer is yes you'll get branded
and that's
a great problem to have that means that
you're going to become one of those
writers
that becomes a go-to oh this guy can
really write
family tween girl films you know and
it's like that's the person they're
gonna go to when they need a writer who
can do that
if you write too many you know different
ideas
if you present all your scripts all of a
sudden then uh
you know a a creative executive might go
this is a great script do you have
anything else like that
so they can see if you're consistent
with your ideas with your talent and if
you can bring
fresh ideas to the same goldmine genre
so are you saying that let's suppose i'm
again the screenwriter that i should
have
three tween girls or i could have one
tween girl
one aging superhero and the other one
a family christmas story where the dog
is lost and then
comes home again i would say i would say
focus on one if you want
if you want uh we we have family
christmas dog adventure is one of my
one of the gold mine genres it doesn't
have to be a dog it doesn't have to be
christmas either but it's more a holiday
themed animal film that's very very
family safe
you can write three of those so you
could change the holiday you could maybe
change the animal
but you got to stay in alignment with
that if you want to do tween girl films
you got to do tween girl films all the
way maybe they can be you know
in a different state uh maybe but their
problems pretty much have to be the same
in one maybe it's magic where dreams can
come true magically one day
another could be that uh her
sweet 16 present i don't know if it's a
car or something like that
uh some dream scenario like that uh
actually has the magical ability to
travel i'm just coming with random ideas
but it's like you just have to have
fresh innovative ideas to the same
goldmine genre then you become
consistent at that
and you become branded as a writer you
can deliver that fast and innovative
and it's kind of like being an actor who
gets typecast talk to any actor
an actor who's typecast that's like a
dream scenario because they're the first
person that a
casting director will call and you can
do that as a writer too
so get that indeed coming of age which
is part your story part someone else's
story out of your system write it maybe
put it somewhere and then start going to
the red box
seeing what's you said to the left to
the bottom or something around there
just around it yeah just around the big
studio movies you'll see the family dog
adventure movies at the bottom there's
always going to be kid movies with
animals in them at the bottom
several of them usually and then if you
look more in the middle zone
you'll see the big studio whatever a big
studio action film and next to it you'll
see the coming of age
i'm sorry the uh the aged male action
film
comeback film you'll see that kind of
movie next to the big studio one
choose one you love choose the one that
you feel gives you the most creative
ability
a women apparel thriller i mean like
people will knock at these genres like
oh they're so commercial etc
get into them like really get into a
young girl's head a male writer
who can get into a young girl's head and
effectively pull that off
like you're talented and you will get
noticed if you are a
a young female writer and you write a
kick-ass action movie for a
coming-of-age male actor
you'll get attention and if you can do
that consistently like you'll get
noticed
you